si hay malestar hay malestar porque
después de 20 años pues sectores dicen
que no se logra el objetivo porque ahora
afganistán puede ser puede seguir siendo
un refugio de terroristas y eeuu pues
ahora es más inseguro precisamente
porque no se logra el objetivo de acabar
con las de los grupos que estaban dando
refugio a terroristas además hay
malestar y preocupación también porque
pues se viene una ola de inmigrantes
afganos son cerca de 100.000 afganos que
salieron de afganistán a países aliados
que pues vendrán futuramente a eeuu y
eso podría generar un costo político
interno alto para el gobierno de john
dryden y pues también hay malestar
porque es otra guerra larga en la que no
se logra el objetivo y se tiene que
salir minimizando los daños
lo que se piensa es que bardem se
apresuró para terminar esta guerra en
afganistán pensando en que no
coincidiera con el vigésimo aniversario
de los ataques del 11 de septiembre y
con las elecciones de medio término en
el horizonte
claro sin embargo hay analistas que
dicen que el avance de los talibanes en
afganistán era imparable que además el
gobierno de trump hizo unas concesiones
a los talibanes dejando en libertad a
cerca de 5000 talibanes muchos de ellos
líderes de este grupo y además pues que
esto era un gesto voy a pasar
independientemente de la retirada si era
en agosto o en junio así que pues
aunque pueda ser un argumento que usen
en campaña los republicanos y muchos
dicen que sin duda lo será prácticamente
el gobierno de job aiden no tenía opción
era retirarse ahora además teniendo en
cuenta la retirada del presidente afgano
de la capital de kabul esto dejó
prácticamente pues sólo a los militares
estadounidenses en afganistán que
tuvieron que retirarse precisamente por
estas variables que no controlaba el
gobierno estadounidense y una pregunta
que ya que se hacen muchas personas
habrá un reconocimiento de la
administración bailén hacia el gobierno
talibán
a diálogos diplomáticos la embajada de
eeuu en kabul sigue cerrada seguirá
cerrada para temas consulares y otros
temas diplomáticos se operará desde
otras embajadas de la región y es sin
duda una de las preguntas que quedan
pendientes es hasta qué punto eeuu va a
esperar para reconocer a tal llevar a
los talibanes y afganistán como un
estado y darle legitimidad muchos dicen
que esto es una herramienta que va a
usar
joe biden para poder presionar a los
talibanes de cara que cumplan sus
obligaciones en derechos humanos y sobre
todo en el trato de la mujer y el
corredor humanitario para seguir pues
dejando salir gente de afganistán por el
aeropuerto de kabul